la colère gronde devant le théâtre de
l'odéon dans le 6e arrondissement de
paris sont plusieurs centaines à s'être
rassemblés contre la fermeture des
salles de spectacles au théâtre de
l'odéon qui épargne est hautement
symbolique souvenez vous en mai 68 il
avait également été occupé par des
militants engagés et puis c'était devenu
un lieu de meetings politiques
aujourd'hui beaucoup et 10 l'histoire se
répète ils sont toujours devant ce
théâtre de l'odéon à l'appel des
syndicats
tous les jours à 14 heures ils se
rassemblent ici
plusieurs revendications sont grandi
notamment
il demande des mesures d'accompagnement
pour les réouverture des salles de
spectacles et puis également la
prolongation de l'année blanche pour les
intermittents du spectacle et surtout le
retrait de l'assurance le chômage le
monde de la culture qui est à l'arrêt
depuis plusieurs mois est très frustré
mécontents et qui ne se sent pas et
écoutez je vous propose d'écouter ces
deux comédiens à qui nous avons pu
parler on vient de subir un nom de
fermeture des théâtres donc on est dans
une situation où la france n'a plus
accès à l'art à la culture les musées
sont fermés les théâtres sont fermés
c'est une chose qui devient
insupportable et pour nous qui sommes
des acteurs et actrices du de la culture
ou de l'art en france et en même temps
pour les spectateurs
je pense que si les artistes ne parle
pas
il y a une majorité de la population qui
se sent pas soutenu
nous sommes porteurs de paroles et ce
qui a été terrible ces derniers mois
c'est qu'avec les lieux de culture fermé
il n'y a plus qu'une seule parole qui
est celle du média en continu et puis il
ya ceux qui se disent être allés grand
oublié de cette crise sanitaire les
guides conférenciers nous avons pu leur
parler ils sont également ici devant le
théâtre de l'odéon et ils viennent se
rassemblent pour soutenir les
intermittents du spectacle et il ne peut
plus travailler depuis plus d'un an
maintenant également
ils demandent à faire partie du régime
de l'intermittence je vous propose de
les écouter mois jusqu'à présent je n'ai
pratiquement pas travailler j'ai eu de
la chance de travailler quelques jours
entre deux confinement mais voilà c'est
vrai je suis en train d'égrainer mai
dernier jour de pôle emploi donc on est
en train de tous de mourir à petit feu
j'ai des collègues à moi qui sont déjà
qu'ils n'ont plus de droit
certains sont tombés dans le rsa dont
d'autres n'ont pas eu dont n'ont pas le
droit au rsa il faut que nous obtenions
un statut d'intermittent il faut que le
statut d'intermittent soit le même pour
tous les interdits dans intermittents du
spectacle les intermittents de l'emploi
et surtout il faut que ce statut ne
soient détruits pour personne pas pour
les intermittents du spectacle et il
faut que ceux qui en ont qui en ont été
éjectés depuis plusieurs années il faut
qu'il revienne dans le statut tel qu'il
était
quand il était encore suffisamment
protecteur le 22 mars il y aura la
réunion du conseil national des
professions du spectacle qui sera
présidée par roselyne bachelot la
ministre de la culture et peut-être par
jean castex est une des demandes
également des manifestants ici présents
la colère gronde et elle va continuer
puisque tous les jours à l'appel de la
cgt les manifestants se rassemblent ici
le devant le théâtre de l'odéon